hello what welcome to see your plan our
penguin let's see what we get here
probably the ratty gambit a g6 else is
one of the more solid lines where I
think that um wyd usually enjoys a
slight advantage ok I'm going to play
this in a somewhat restrained way you
don't have to play default all the time
I'll see if I was interesting he intends
to go d 40 m to block my bishop I don't
want that to happen Bishop Jake's ok I
rather expected night takes but it's
it's yeah it's probably playable you you
kind of have to move it again I'm not
sure knight c6 yeah well I 96 looked a
little bit odd so yeah do you some d 4
years interesting ok I'll go for it
before you go with a knight c6 open open
this up
the main no idea that white has and this
is this kind of position often is that
you add a little bit quicker on those
open files and get to use the c6 square
the night has not yet played mahjongg
another beer aight night and quite often
you can use that square ok here i guess
Knight to f3 every treating is from I
can go efore yeah actually I can do a
form and then then I should but ok again
knight c6 doesn't work night CM night
bt7 I have Queen to c6 even so it was
quite nice he might play a five but then
I should drop back so I think MOOCs you
warn ya I don't think he can do much on
the diagonal aha ok so here Quincy sick
sister and standard reaction it doesn't
have a tactic here right now briefly
thinking I can some night takes you four
but that doesn't work at all ok so here
I could take and go knight c6 but this
is not dead well supported ok
would be cool to prevent 95 but I don't
don't see how that should be possible
and see 53 is quite annoying
hmm okay
hmm I don't want to take this if
possible but how to do something
different knight c6 a it's got 95 this
is not not all that brilliant quite
quite surprisingly to be honest why
should have at least a slight advantage
but somehow it doesn't feel like it and
that unprotect everything it looks kind
of wrong now night to d3 yeah baby that
still works ha strange stuff I mean it
just has a week c 6 square and it
doesn't mean much maybe because my d
three squares also week maybe
I came at least at least this is right
this simple to play now I mean I've
screwed up the time royally as usual so
I have to make sure to play somewhat
easy moves
frickin time sorry for that rope d7 I
might take take and take you sound
can we enter the primo
now so we just put this is giving away
seven and another pond I mean it's a
double bond but still night at five is
also interesting here I think I do this
this is probably better just just go G
for next and attack that pawn instead of
taking it trying to preserve the
structure maybe but should be six ticks
ticks afternoon take care of the time a
little bit him time morning caught a
slight cold the hot weather and whenever
you got into a air conditioned space
which was actually nice with Peter to do
you have this this danger of catching
catching cold I can sell here keeping
this night out my night doesn't have all
that much how do I get this back into
the game night age six or something 93 I
have a toilets I don't think any big
issue maybe I a three is bad actually
should have played a three would have
been would have been a bit better
already said this is too connected
passers King f4 though okay maybe King
f4 is the problem that's possible that's
a little bit awkward and I don't have
time to really figure it out I yes to go
back now I can also go back for this
said winning or not I is good King g5
uh-huh totally forgot about that that's
awful and you can go back to g5 oh I'm
such an idiot oh that was really bad I
know I screwed this up again time-wise
here from winning ending to this stuff
which is now of course losing I know
it's a draw I mean okay wins on time
maybe like forfeits I'm telling a
terrible game Oh what was that you just
get a totally winning ending here maybe
I should have just taken the bloody
thing I mean never did also is a winning
ending yeah okay so we have a look at
this so a little bit of a strange
opening and it was really surprised oops
that was not intended but I didn't have
at least a slight edge she SAT with this
week 6 square sorry I'm keep pressing
the wrong button but this night a 60-53
sm is also something very relevant so
maybe this is the reason why I didn't
have anything at all yeah the computer
just gives a slight edge for white but
nothing special it seems to be wrong due
to route 27 once the play Knights is 6
after all and after this Bishop
okay that's not a move that I looked at
but it is quite quite reasonable of
course taking e7 okay so what did happen
here d 8 yeah i mean i would see a
dumbest yeah was I was quite happy that
the position is easy to play now and by
now it is difficult again for him loop
the eight as a threat and took a this
blunder d7 and actually blunders the
game but I still 96 I could have gone 96
I'm just making many little mistakes as
well so 96 is a lot stronger keeping his
King out very easy it's okay maybe I was
just playing it too complicated here
wanting to preserving the structure and
I made it again a couple of mistakes
yeah a three is stronger oh no it's not
yes 94 oh wow let's again and then there
those two points okay strategically a 3
is stronger you know because i want you
have given a bit pawn before but it
doesn't work technically yet here
there's not much to say it's a
completely winning position where I
screw it up so what does win night age
six wins and this doesn't win to age
five king of 486 this and now I have to
play correctly to to do it 94 is still
winning yeah i was i was completely miss
counting you know i was thinking i go
here here here but of course he is just
in time to go to g5 this is very very
stupid mistake if i go go like him he
cannot take with the night now on g4 yes
to do this this and now i'm picking
picking this up
or setting along these look at and this
wins because I'm quick at the queenside
I will win both pawn cm yeah and this
you probably don't need to reduce
necessarily but ok at ten seconds yeah
out of shape I don't know what it is I
played really well and then now I'm
playing like a completed yet so I have
to get a couple of wins in to get into
normal rating regions again ok thanks
for watching